Show Business can be a sticky business.
Such is the case with the enormous "The Walking
Dead" series — there's been a legal dispute
ongoing behind the scenes between AMC — the
network which airs the show and its spin-off
prequel, "Fear the Walking Dead" — and Robert
Kirkman, the comic book writer who created
the whole franchise.
What's at stake?
Millions of dollars in net profits from rerun
and streaming exhibitions of the show that
Kirkman, along with his co-producers claim
they have not seen in the wake of the show's
major success despite contractual guarantees.
They have challenged the amount that the cable
network has been shelling out to them via
a breach of contract lawsuit.
While AMC recently settled a suit from former
showrunner Frank Darabont and the talent agency
CAA for a bit over $200 million over "future
revenue sharing related to certain future
streaming exhibition of 'The Walking Dead'
and 'Fear The Walking Dead,'" the suit initiated
by Kirkman and his co-plaintiffs has lingered
on.
These kinds of conflicts over net receipts
are common in Hollywood, and have only grown
more complex since the advent and rapid proliferation
of streaming, a model not contemplated by
many legacy contracts.
This case is of particular interest because
of the eye-popping numbers involved.
"The Walking Dead" is one of the most successful
franchises in television history.
It's already spawned two spin-off series,
and although the flagship show is about to
make its final bow with it’s 11th and final
season, AMC seems determined to keep the universe
alive long into the future.
A July 2020 decision initially dealt a blow
to the plaintiffs after Los Angeles Superior
Court Judge Buckley ruled that AMC had correctly
interpreted the terms of the contracts in
regard to the licensing fees owed on seven
counts.
However, now it appears that a legal change
is in the wind.
A bit over a year later, July 27th, 2021,
Judge Buckley ruled that Kirkman and his co-plaintiffs
could pursue further punitive damages and
legal theories via two amended claims.
These claims accuse AMC of "tortious interference"
and "alleged breach of the implied covenant
of good faith and fair dealing," according
to The Hollywood Reporter.
To clear up some of the legalese, the second
claim accuses AMC of defining the terms of
profit sharing to guarantee Kirkman and the
others would make no money.
Meanwhile, the first alleges that AMC acted
deliberately to give its sister company an
advantage in these matters.
Orin Snyder of the law firm Gibson Dunn explained
the decision to The Hollywood Reporter as
an unimpressive overture:
"It is just as meritless as the 7 out of 7
claims we beat at trial last year, and we
are confident we will defeat this new claim
as well."
Most creators, like Kirkman, contract for
a percentage of backend receipts in their
original option deals.
The most popular method of calculating this
compensation is Modified Adjusted Gross Receipts.
There are several standard ways of calculating
it, and it can all get pretty complicated,
but it's basically how the money is calculated
up and divided among the people legally obligated
to have it.
Long story short, the bad faith that Kirkman
alleges is that AMC always intended its calculation
to leave him with as little as possible thanks
to “creative calculations.”
While Snyder is correct to point out that
this preliminary ruling doesn't have any bearing
on the legal merits of Kirkman's case — and
what do you expect him to say he represents
AMC — the judge did see enough evidence
of malice as alleged in the complaint to proceed
to trial.
If Kirkman can show by a preponderance of
the evidence that AMC did contract in bad
faith, and never intended its calculation
to yield any proceeds whatsoever, he might
just land a favorable verdict.
That verdict would set a very dangerous precedent
for the entire industry, and might have other
creators unsatisfied with their paltry backend
checks looking up the name of a good attorney.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about a bunch
of fancy legal proceedings are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.